how did you meet her Bumble I swiped
right she was an Iranian girl who's into
fitness and when I met her on our first
date we talked for like four hours only
about business and I was like this is
great I don't have to pretend to like
what you like she was telling me what
her dreams and aspirations were she
wanted to open a gym someday at the time
I think I had five I was like I'm
starting this new thing you should do it
with me she didn't really believe me yet
she had built up her own personal
training business like a roster of
clients and so she had her own thing
going and so I went and I launched three
gyms came back I process like 100 Grand
in front of her and she was like what
the hell is this is this legal and I was
like yes and she was like okay she ended
up quitting and joining me there because
she knew it was I was good at it